Mike Gordon: Kongregate was founded by Jim and Emily Greer.
They have decided to create a web platform for developers
And independent games.
Initially this platform was named the platform for games on YouTube.
My name is Mike Gordon, Vice President for Publishing
In Kongregate.
We've seen a lot of web developers moving to use
Mobile, so we need a partner like Kongregate
To enter the mobile world.
Peter Eckmens: My name is Peter Eckmens
One of the advanced producers in Kongregate.
One of the first challenges we faced when we switched to mobile
Is to realize what he is looking for
Game users in the gaming market.
Tammy Levy: We were aware of what we could do on the web
To find out what he likes and does not like game users,
However, we did not have these tools on mobile.
And then we started a painstaking research on how
Translate it?
My name is Tammy Levy, Product Manager
Mobile games in Kongregate.
Mike Gordon: The Google Play Developer Console is available
Application developers have a lot of useful tools
In a manner that is easy to use.
Peter Eckmens: A good way was not needed
To distribute versions.
Using alpha testing frameworks and use
Demo on Google Play, we're easily able to do so.
We can add mailing lists or groups of people
Or Google Forums, rather than individually mailing APK over
E-mail, we can only say "click on this
Site and accept laboratory status
Go to download the version.
We need only that.
Tammy Levy: Is this the reason for experimenting?
The thing is not thrown for everyone.
Because if proven incompetence the thing is considered how to improve it
Before making it available to everyone?
Peter Eckmens: One of the first uses of an experiment
Store Lists Conduct an experiment on binary symbols.
Through which we introduced a symbolic hero in the game
In front of the helicopter, which were of units
Inside the game.
We found that the users who showed them the helicopter code
They have an increase in downloads by 92%
Compared to users who saw the symbolic hero.
And then we moved to the screenshot experience
Where we discovered a 14% increase in downloads
Users who have the new look have a different shape.
Then we moved to the written text about the game,
Where we developed an explanation of the strategy and types
Units that appear to users.
When we tried all that, we discovered an increase
At all levels of the painting.
And when calculating everything
We found a 45% increase in downloads
Users who have chosen the new format have.
This was a great experience for us.
Tammy Levy: It was very exciting
So we started to apply it to each game separately.
We are fully aware that the results we will get
It will be effective.
We took advantage of that
The certainty that we are
We offer the best game.
Hence we recommend all developers in the world
Taking advantage of all the tools available in
The developer console to ensure you qualify yourself towards success.
Mike Gordon: There is a tremendous amount of
The information is available in the Developers console.
You can access it whenever you want.
It is also easy to use because it is quite clear
Its information is very useful.
Peter Eckmens: Non-renewal makes you take
One pattern of the first impression,
So make sure you try everything,
Because you have to make sure that the art you love will find
Echo to users as well,
They may not be right all the time.